- I want to help you, AMD, free of charge.
Just drop by the lab and I'm gonna have
the team show you how to benchmark a GPU
so then you can choose a price
that reflects its performance
because, frankly, you guys
are all over the road here.
The RX 7600,
the card you're launching
today manages to get handily
outclassed by your own products.
(record scratching)
Is what I was going to say.
Then, on Monday afternoon,
just 39 hours from launch,
AMD dropped the price!
Let's go, gamers!
We're gonna have a rough cut
of our original review
on floatplane.com/ltt
if you're curious, by the way,
but the gist of it is this:
we liked the card, but
didn't like the price.
Well, now,
it is $60 less than the launch price
of its predecessor and it's
within $10 of our suggestion
that we thought would make it
competitive, which is nice,
but then they also dropped the price
on some of their last gen products,
making those even more attractiver.
There is a lot to unpack here,
but one thing we know for
sure is that thanks to AMD,
there are finally some, not one,
some decent mainstream cards
that gamers can actually afford.
Let's start with the new kid on the block.
The all-new Navi 33 GPU at
the heart of the 7600 is built
on AMD's latest RDNA 3 architecture,
which comes with some key benefits,
like the addition of AI cores that, well,
don't seem to do much right
now, but in the future,
we're expecting that to change.
You know, fine wine driver
development and all of that.
And right out of the gate,
RDNA 3 also comes with substantially
improved ray-tracing performance,
but then so does the competition.
And AMD has only made things
more difficult for themselves.
Just last month ,
they were over there throwing rocks
at NVIDIA over the lack of memory
on their more affordable cards.
I guess they forgot about
their own glass house here.
"But this card is for 1080P
where eight gigs is enough," says AMD.
Unfortunately, that's not entirely true.
Have a look.
In "F1 22," AMD pulls off both
a big win and an own goal.
Their last gen 6700 XT
leads the entire field,
beating even the 4070 that
costs almost twice as much,
but then their shiny
new 7600 falls squarely
in the middle of the pack
and behind their own 6650 XT,
a last gen card that at
press time costs anywhere
from 10 to $30 less.
Rough start and definitive proof
that you should completely
ignore performance rumors
for upcoming products.
In "Far Cry 6,"
AMD manages to avoid beating themselves
at their own game by keeping ahead
of their own lower priced
cards, albeit barely.
And the same goes for "Hitman 3"
where the most interesting
result is actually the Arc A770.
Intel's software team has clearly
been working their butts
off to the point where
they now kind of sort of have
a card that manages to keep
up with the competition, or it did anyway.
But can you keep up with this
message from our sponsor?
- The Ridge!
Father's Day is coming up.
Luckily,
Ridge is having one of their
biggest sales of the year.
Give the dads in your life a unique
and functional Ridge wallet or key case
so they can do dad things,
like brag about their wallet and keys.
Check The Ridge out at the
link below and make dad proud.
- As we tested more and more games,
we realized that the main takeaway
is that for 1080P gaming,
you really don't need to spend
more than a few hundred bucks
on a replacement for
your aging mid-tier GPU.
Even in "Returnal" and "Cyberpunk,"
we saw average frame rates
above 60 fps across our
entire stable of modern cards,
even if the 1% lows are a bit lower.
With that said, there
is a big asterisk here.
Look at the results for
"The Last of Us Part 1."
The 3060 has been quietly
getting its butt handed
to it the whole time, and then, boom!
It's out in front of the 7600.
Interesting.
We're gonna talk about that in a moment.
First, if you're a 1080P gamer,
AMD's new card seems to slot
into their lineup very nicely,
falling behind its bigger,
older brother, the 6700 XT,
by about 20% in both
price and performance.
While it's little, though
still older brother,
the 6650 XT gives up just 5% performance
on average and doesn't net you
much in the way of savings.
Given that this is a
newer GPU that will likely
receive driver support for longer,
the 7600 is getting very close
to a recommendation here,
kinda like how we'd recommend
an insulated water bottle
from lttstore.com.
But, first, we need to talk about VRAM.
Both Team Green and Team Red are adamant
that eight gigs of GDDR
6 is enough for 1080P.
And yet we found real world examples
of games that did struggle,
especially those pesky PlayStation ports.
This was very apparent
when we saw the 3060 12 gig
suddenly outperforming the
supposedly faster RX 7600.
And whether you like it or not,
this is gonna be a trend, gamers.
For over a decade now,
consoles have been what dictates the rate
of growth for hardware requirements.
It's no coincidence that the PS5
and the Xbox Series X both
feature a shared memory
architecture of 16 gigs
and 10 gigs respectively,
and now all of a sudden,
we're seeing games
developed for these consoles
that can demand significantly more VRAM
than an eight gig GPU can provide.
And with the potential for
a mid-generation refresh
to these consoles,
it's not entirely unrealistic to expect
that VRAM requirements
could increase further
in the coming years.
Take it with a grain of salt,
rumors, and all of that.
The issue on top of that, though,
is all of this is just for 1080P.
If you own a 1440P display,
you might desire that extra
VRAM today, right now.
Across our suite of games in 1440P,
our rankings remained largely
similar to the 1080P results,
but it should be noted that the cards
with the extra VRAM tend to
hold their positions better.
Intel in particular starts to pull ahead
and even managed some small
victories where it lost before.
And the 3060 12 gig holds its position
despite its much weaker GPU.
Of course,
we were a lot more upset about all of this
before the 7600 got a new price point
and NVIDIA is clearly
still the worst offender.
Moving on.
We know these are obviously not 4K cards,
at least not without the help
of their respective
super sampling solutions,
but our pattern continues
with the 3060 12 gig
closing its performance gap
versus the 7600 while
Intel extends its own.
To be clear,
we wouldn't recommend any of these cards
for 4K ultra gaming, say, for the 4070,
but what's cool is that
we no longer have to
say the same thing about ray tracing.
7600 isn't exactly a ray tracing monster,
but it did better than we
expected at 1080P native.
And looking at our results
with FidelityFX Super Resolution,
which has massively improved,
even if it does still
lag behind NVIDIA's DLSS,
you can get a decent
1440P gaming experience.
Although that is still a little
like saying my Civic
can do 130 miles an hour
as long as it's on a steep hill.
So then, performance,
pretty solid for the price
and going with next gen comes
with other upsides too, right?
Like a big leap in efficiency?
No, actually.
20% more performance over last gen
is gonna cost you a 20%
increase in total board power.
I mean, at least it
doesn't overheat, though?
Yes, it doesn't.
And while it isn't the quietest card,
it's not offensively loud
despite its small size.
We also do get display
port 2.1, so that's cool.
But AMD removed the one cable USB-C output
that is so awesome on the 7900 series.
So, oh, but what about productivity?
Well,
NVIDIA dominates Blender thanks
to its excellent CUDA integration.
And while the AV1 encoding
times are competitive
with the more expensive 46 DTI,
that's a nice plus for YouTube streamers.
The RX 7600's H264 and H265 encoding
are nothing to write home about.
Sorry, Twitch streamers.
And in SPECviewperf,
it sits right in the middle of the pack,
though I doubt that dazzling
productivity performance
would've persuaded the 7600's
target audience anyway.
Not that it really needs it.
Assuming you can actually find
one at MSRP, the RX 7600 is,
and I can't believe I get to
say this for the first time in years,
an attractive mainstream gaming card.
However,
I'm sure we weren't the
only ones who were surprised
by the price change and AMD's partners
may have been caught with board designs
that make this new
price point impractical.
So it could be some time
before the market is flush
with sub $300 GPUs, at
least from this gen.
The good news is AMD has
lots of other options
with fresh price cuts as well.
For as low as $320 for the 6700 XT,
you'll get a roughly 20 to 25%
performance uplift for
an equal bump in price,
albeit with a higher cost of ownership
from its increased power draw.
The 6650 XT, meanwhile, is
looking like a pretty okay,
similarly priced alternative.
And the 6600 is kind of
the quiet star of the show
if you can get it for the
price we're seeing now.
Just 200 dollaridoos?
And then there's NVIDIA
who has transitioned
from making GPUs for gamers
to making GPUs for fans of NVIDIA.
And now,
it's time to see our original outro
for this video where I low-key
absolutely (bleep) nailed it.
It's not a budget productivity workhorse
nor is it a mainstream
level gaming godsend.
It just kind of sits there
with its main differentiators
being shiny and new.
Is that the play, then?
Try and get people who want the new shiny
and aren't doing much research?
- [Narrator] Incoming
transmission from the future.
- It's been six months and in the wake
of recent catastrophic event,
AMD has decided to slash
prices on their 7600.
Now that it's available for $259.99,
it's gone from no-buy to no-brainer.
And it's an especially good
value compared to the 4060,
which is still $300 because
NVIDIA don't do no price drops.
Anyway, AMD's AI cores,
they do something now,
so that's cool.
And if any of this is wrong,
just be sure to tune into the When Show
on Friday, November 24th, 2023
to let future Linus know that
he went to the wrong time.
Oh God, they're coming!
(gun firing)
(man yelling)
Don't forget to tell Linus
about the segue to our sponsor.
- Vessi!
It's springtime,
which means rain can still show
up and ruin your day like
an annoying neighbor.
But that's fine because
hello, we have Vessi shoes!
Vessi claims their shoes
are 100% waterproof
so we can go step into as
many puddles as we want.
Their Dyma-tex technology
keeps their shoes light
and breathable while still
being stretchy and comfortable.
Also, all of their products
are vegan and cruelty-free.
Maybe you're planning a trip to get away
from some of this miserable weather.
Don't forget to pack a pair of Vessies.
Their stretchiness means
they can easily pack
into your luggage or carry-on.
Rain or shine, here or there,
it's always a great occasion
to wear a pair of Vessies.
(man speaking in foreign language)
Go to vessi.com/linustechtips and get 15%
off your purchase with code LinusTechTips.
- Another time loop successfully closed.
If you enjoyed this video,
you can check out maybe
the coolest implementation
of RDNA 3, the ROG Ally.
That thing is sick and
really, really efficient.